Selling concert tickets is… not especially hard.
Despite what your $20 “service fee”
would suggest, on a scale of difficult
problems to solve, it lies somewhere between
light bulb installation and check cashing.
The only remotely hard part — you might say
a ticketing company’s one job — is to handle
the extremely predictable surge of traffic
the day Taylor Swift tickets go on sale.
So, of course, that’s exactly what TicketMaster
failed spectacularly at during
her recent “Eras” tour presale.
Traumatized fans told stories of $200 service
fees, cryptic error messages, and $50,000 seats.
Most left with nothing to show for their
eight hours of fighting in the trenches.
Others felt like lottery winners
simply for having been granted
the privilege of paying five, six, or
nine hundred dollars for nosebleeds.
But although demand for this tour
could hardly have been higher,
there’s nothing new about the
unpleasantness of buying tickets.
When service fees commonly
cost more than the actual seat,
it’s no surprise America’s hatred of
TicketMaster makes Comcast look favorable.
How does the company get away with it?
“Because,” common sense would say, “they can.”
TicketMaster is so deeply embedded in the industry
that it’s nearly impossible for large artists to
avoid. Of Taylor Swift’s 52 upcoming shows,
for instance, it sold the tickets for 47.
Not only does it sell twice as many
tickets as its closest competitor,
StubHub, but it also represents performers,
owns venues, and acts as a promoter.
All of this is 100% true.
And yet, it’s not the reason
service fees are astronomical,
scalping is rampant, or buying
tickets, just generally sucks.
Sponsored by Audible. Listen to “Ticket Masters:
The Rise of the Concert Industry
and How the Public Got Scalped”,
or one of thousands of other great audiobooks
for free with the link in the description.
What’s the “right” price for a product?
Ask the seller and they’ll
tell you “that’s easy!”,
the right price is the one
people are willing to pay.
Entire careers and disciplines exist for the
sole purpose of finding that
number with penny precision.
And because price has the largest impact
on profit — more so than production costs
or even volume sold — the science of
pricing has gotten pretty darn good.
Through surveys, trends, and algorithms,
companies systematically deconstruct the
value consumers place on each feature.
A $3 gallon of milk might derive 30
cents of its value from being reduced
fat and a nickel from its packaging.
They can then use those values to
determine the theoretical price
of a new product or a matrix of products
with different combinations of features.
Concerts, on the other hand, are
just about the opposite of milk.
Not only are they an experience but
they’re also highly emotionally charged.
Besides, no two shows are the same.
Taylor Swift will only ever play the Eras
Tour in Kansas City on July 7th once.
Now, none of this would faze an economist.
After all, there are many one-of-a-kind products
— houses, paintings, and used cars, for example.
When you don’t know the
consumer’s willingness to pay,
the simple “Econ 101” solution
is to force them to reveal it.
In other words, an auction.
All the technology required
to double or triple Taylor
Swift’s profit overnight existed on eBay in 1995.
The problem, of course, is that artists are
in the business of cultivating goodwill.
These higher prices would effectively
exclude many of their biggest fans,
bruising their image, and limiting
the long-term growth of their fanbase.
Take a second to appreciate
what this means: Instead,
artists artificially price their tickets hundreds
or even thousands of dollars below market value.
We know this because the same
tickets are immediately resold
for many multiples of their original price.
Remember, from a purely economic perspective,
the “right” price is the one
people are willing to pay.
And a natural consequence is the opportunity for
scalpers to buy low and sell high. If Taylor Swift
won’t charge what she’s worth, some random dude
in Romania is more than happy to do it for her.
At the same time, artists are also
in the business of… making money.
They still want to capture
some of that extra value.
And one of the ways they balance
these two competing interests is
by secretly withholding many of their best seats.
Some of these “holds” may be given to
friends and family. Others, however,
are sold directly to brokers who turn around and
sell them to you at the prevailing market rate.
In 2011, Katy Petty’s contract
was leaked to the public,
revealing that she, like many
musicians, did just that.
In other words, artists get to have their
cake and eat it too — protecting their
image with affordable primary ticket sales while
profiting off far more expensive secondary sales.
Now, you might argue that artists
themselves are victims of the larger
industry — one they have no
choice but to participate in.
This is true.
Unless Taylor Swift wants to play for crowds
of 800 people at the Timbuktu county fair,
TicketMaster is effectively the only game in town.
That’s because it signs 3-5
year exclusive contracts with
the vast majority of large, desirable venues.
All the star power of Sinatra, Elvis,
and Lennon combined would be worthless
against these air-tight contracts.
If you want to play at these venues —
which, for the most popular artists,
really means play at all —
TicketMaster comes with them.
But what critics of the company often miss by
fixating on its monopoly is the question why.
Why do companies sign these
exclusive deals with TicketMaster?
Once upon a time, ticketing was a cost
for venues — a service, like security,
that they outsourced to the lowest bidder.
What TicketMaster did — it’s innovation,
if you can call it that — was approach
these venues with an offer: “What if,
instead of you paying us, we paid you?”
Sure, part of the reason TicketMaster got
so big was by swallowing up its competitors,
but it also did so by promising
to make concert venues more money.
For cash-strapped public stadiums especially, this
guaranteed source of revenue proved irresistible.
It did this with the two most hated words
in the English language: service fees.
Every show is different, but these
fees are typically shared between
some combination of TicketMaster,
the venue, promoter, and/or artist.
The truth — though it pains me to say this —
is that the vast majority of TicketMaster’s
customers love it. It’s just that we are
not its customers. We are just collateral
damage caught in a web of intermediaries
fighting to capture the value of live music.
That’s what the Justice Department
decided in 1995 after a years-long
investigation — that its true customers
were perfectly happy with the status quo.
A decade later, a Federal District Court
in California reached the same conclusion.
There’s no doubt TicketMaster
wields far more control than any
one company should have over the music industry.
In fact, since it merged with Live Nation in 2010,
TicketMaster itself owns many of the
venues that grant it exclusivity.
These things are easy to understand.
What’s not as well understood is
that greater competition isn’t,
in this case, an effective solution.
Remember: ticketing companies compete to give
more money to venues in the form of service fees.
Split TicketMaster in two and they
would bid service fees up, not down.
Yes, the company’s vertical integration
— spanning venues, promotion, ticketing,
and managing — is incredibly concerning.
But let’s not forget that it had no trouble
securing these exclusive contracts well
before it merged with Live Nation in 2010.
In 1994, for instance, it had exclusive deals
with 63% of American arenas and concert halls.
Now, if any of this surprised
you — that’s the point.
If you assumed service fees were
entirely the fault of TicketMaster,
you are proof that the company doesn’t just
skim profit, it also offers a valuable service.
What TicketMaster is is a reputational shield.
Ticketing is the ugly part of the business
— the business part of the business.
So, artists, who don’t want to touch
it with a ten-foot pole, outsource it.
The implicit agreement is that, while fees get
spread around, TicketMaster, alone, takes the hit.
And when fans can’t get seats, it’s
TicketMaster who delivers the bad news.
But the critical thing to not lose
sight of is that above all these
intermediaries is the only absolute,
unbreakable monopoly: the artist.
Though he may be on all our
iPhones, there’s only one Bono.
The top 1% of artists negotiate from
a position of extraordinary strength.
This may sound like an obvious truism — “the
most popular artists are powerful… duh!” — but
it’s something fans, in their eagerness
to forgive their heroes, often forget.
Consider, for instance, how they get paid.
Artists, through their agents,
who typically take a percentage of their
earnings, are approached by a promoter.
Promoters are the heart of the whole
operation. Beyond managing, scheduling,
and, yes, promoting, by far their most
important role is to underwrite the event.
While artists receive a guarantee — an
up-front fee for their performance — say,
a million dollars, the promoter may
make more than a million dollars or
they might make far less — they assume that risk.
The most popular musicians —
confident in their ability to
attract crowds — often choose a
percentage of the door instead.
And the higher their guarantee or percentage,
the less money is left over for everyone else.
When top artists can demand as much as
one hundred and five percent — more than
the total ticket sales —it’s no wonder
these costs eventually ripple down to
you and I in the form of $12 pretzels and $50
service fees — it had to come from somewhere.
And that’s just one part of the contract.
Musicians also help determine ticket
prices, fees, presale requirements,
and whether or not to use dynamic pricing
— which adjusts prices algorithmically.
This is not at all to paint artists
as the villains and TicketMaster
as an innocent scapegoat. They’re
all complicit to varying degrees.
But if your goal is to affect change,
calling for the breakup of TicketMaster
is more a satisfying method of venting
frustration than it is an effective solution.
The real hope lies with the artist — the
party both with the most power and
the one most responsive to fans.
It may not be the musician's fault
that the industry is what it is,
but if anyone can negotiate on behalf
of all of us, it’s Taylor Swift, who,
in 2015, almost single-handedly
changed how artists are paid on
Apple Music and more recently fought
back against her own record label.
Just as the costs imposed by the top 1%
of artists ripple down to the rest of us,
these privileged few can also set
better terms that benefit everyone.
Music history is filled with exactly
that — bands standing up for their fans,
sometimes to borderline comical degrees.
When the jam band “The String Cheese Incident”
was refused the right to sell its own tickets in
the early 2000s, it threatened to hand
out cash to thousands of volunteers,
who would go buy them on their behalf at the
box office, which was exempt from service fees.
The Grateful Dead, likewise, fought TicketMaster
for the right to sell half of its tickets directly
to fans. In order to prevent scalpers from
buying more than the permitted number of tickets,
it would spread thousands of order slips out on
the floor and look for duplicate handwriting.